well young man are you proud of this
little debacle I believe the detective
will be quite disappointed
I assume you came to recover these
children take them and go not without my
sister Tora Markov we know the League of
Shadows has her stay your tongue when
addressing the demons head it is fine
sensei boy the shadows main beam have
your sister but I am no longer head of
the shadows as you can see there are no
shadows here in fact I'm no longer part
of the light your eyes we shall go is
many things but a liar isn't one of them
would the great one care to reveal who
is running the shadows now no he would
not it's not my dad is it no my sister
get out
[Music]
gray sir Oh your memory is finally
returning eczema
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new young justice to break down
the couple really big reveals a whole
bunch of WTF moments so we'll do this
just like I did my video last week for
Wally West if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a new round of that DC
Universe giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite WTF moment from the episode on
the video spoiler warning for episodes 4
through 6 you can see we skipped a
couple of really big Batman stories in
the time jumps between seasons but I'll
try to explain what they're doing with
that because I'm sure they're all just
setting stuff up for later in the season
so working away through all the episodes
top 10 WTF here we go number 10 all the
Roy's in the Google VR goggles
obviously it's meant to be a parody of
Google VR which is an actual thing in
real life but if you've ever watched any
of classic Star Trek The Next Generation
you know that when you start seeing all
your characters walking around seemingly
hypnotized by a really cool video game
and it's a sort of virtual reality
environment and you don't know what's
really going on with the tech behind it
then it's probably gonna turn out to be
something really really bad
think about the lights soda in the early
seasons like anything that's
mass-produced that everybody in the show
seems to be hooked on like oh this is so
great even barbara gordon is hooked on
this Google VR stuff that's going on so
clearly it's going to be terrible it's
probably gonna have something to do with
the light later this season all the team
Harper stuff was great quick reminder on
Roy and all of his clones because they
call it the Harper family like they had
the security business that they're all
probably going to be operating together
so beardy here the leader of the group
is Will Harper he's red arrow he's a
clone of the original Roy who had a
daughter with chesh ire named Leanne
she's the little girl that you've been
seeing everytime we go to his house the
big guy like even bigger guy is Jim
Harper he's Guardian and he's also
another clone of the original Roy the
original version of Roy is the young one
here with the shaved head he goes by
Arsenal and he's the one with the bionic
arm number dying though halo keeps dying
and resurrecting yourself in what seems
like every other episode this would have
liked her new thing learning about her
cool light-based powers and her true
origins which I'll explain in a second
because they are setting up some really
big stuff but the big moment for her was
when she met with Doc
fate and he's like I can't quite tell
what's going on but you feel like an old
soul that's because they're actually
doing the comic book story for her she
was a big part of Batman and the
outsiders in the comics but the reason
why dr. fate says she feels like an old
soul is because she's literally bonded
to the soul of a really old being called
an Oracle so not to be confused with
Oracle Barbara Gordon it's an ancient
entity that emerged from the source wall
at the dawn of the first DC universe so
to speak so it was before the big
Cataclysm that split the single universe
into the modern-day
DC multiverse so she's literally bonded
to a creature that's billions of years
old I'm sure what will happen is is
they'll just find a way to tease that
out over the rest of the series like
she'll start to remember things that the
entity remembers from billions of years
ago and then the entity will somehow
help them in their fight with the light
but number seven remind her about what
happened with Zatanna and why he had to
sacrifice himself to become doctor faith
they sort of touch on that briefly
because it's gonna come back around it's
important that dr. fate be on planet
earth way back in the earlier seasons
when they were fighting Clery on Lord of
Chaos the only way they were able to
defeat him was when Zatanna like girls
that Ana put the helmet of fate on and
used nabu's powers but Naboo said that
in order to protect the earth he would
have to remain there and the only way to
do that is if someone sacrificed
themselves to permanently become dr.
fate he only freed Zatanna
when Zatara agreed to take his place so
because of all that I'm expecting
Clarion to come back and dr. fate will
probably have some huge battle later in
the season there's a lot of setup
happening in these early episodes but
slowly moving at Episode five number six
the war between foragers race in the new
gods so this is obviously a big deal
this is just the beginning of what looks
like a really big battle happening
between new Genesis the new gods in
Darkseid and the forces of apocalypse so
number five we find out fake Orion is
really Miss Martian's younger brother
big WTF moment who's trying to start a
white Martian revolution so he's made
this Faustian bargain
remember that Faustian bargain on the
Martian homeworld to sow dissension on
New Genesis in exchange for new weapons
and forces to overthrow the green and
red Martians so he doesn't know
about the people that he's bargained
with probably gonna turn out to be some
secret plot from desaad in darkseid's
forces to try and destabilize the new
gods so the dark side can continue to
try and conquer the universe and the new
gods will be too busy fighting amongst
themselves to try and deal with them
number four was obviously that crazy
moment when he detonated the
self-destruct devices in those kids
metahuman collars so remember these are
all little kids anytime they kill any of
these metahumans on other planets it's a
little kid that's been forced into
becoming a metahuman he escapes into the
planets core obviously he's gonna be
back before the end of the season it'll
be a big battle for Miss Martian they're
just setting that up for later
moving into Episode six the really big
stuff number three biggest surprise
raesha Ghul says he's no longer part of
the light and no longer the demon says
somebody else is leading the League of
Shadows but he won't say who Artemis
wonders if it's Cheshire or her father
Sports master other to them I think it
makes more sense the Cheshire would be
the person to be leading the league but
we'll find out about that later it could
wind up being someone else other big
surprise baby Damian Wayne and Talia al
Ghul we don't know if Batman knows about
this because he looks relatively new
born like this has happened pretty
recently so unless there's another
really big time jump or they just jack
him up with miracle-gro it'll probably
be a while before we see a version of
like little kid Damian Wayne doing
regular stuff on the TV show maybe
season four but they were always big
time jumps between seasons it was five
years the first time jumped between one
and two and then between two and three
it was two years so if you really want
Damian Wayne to be doing really cool
stuff I think we'll get there eventually
but I think this is just a setup for
more Batman story later this season
because we see a bunch of Batman in the
season 3 trailer but we haven't got a
whole lot of him besides what we saw in
episode 1 number 2 is the revelation
that Tara from the comics obviously is
being forced to work with the League of
Shadows who obviously Rachel Ghul isn't
associated with anymore but it's all
part of her evil comic book backstory if
you haven't seen it Teen Titans Judas
contract does like a version of her
origin story but she starts out as a
plant working with Deathstroke to try
and take down the Teen Titans so I think
Young Justice is just kind of doing
their version of that but number one WTF
obviously a big moment of the episode is
they reveal Red Hood Jason Todd
exist like he's the guy that's standing
here because he starts to remember
Nightwing and racial goal says good
you're remembering so clearly we've
missed a couple really big Batman
stories Batman death in the family and
possibly Batman The Killing Joke because
Barbara Gordon has become Oracle so if
the Joker didn't take her down then
something else really big happened to
her but because they try to be
relatively faithful to the comics I
think somewhere between that time jump
at the end of season 2 in the beginning
of season 3 they had their Killing Joke
moment and that's when she wound up in
the wheelchair but it seems like for
right now Jason Todd is still baking in
the oven like he hasn't gone completely
off the rails and gone back to Gotham
and it seems like they're setting up a
really big Batman family story within
Young Justice so really excited for that
Batman Robin's reunion in whatever young
justices version of under the Red Hood
is going to be but that's basically the
story that's playing out per all these
Jason Todd scenes so a whole lot of big
teasers for stuff that they're gonna pay
off later a lot of Batman stuff
happening in this last episode and don't
forget that they also name-drop wally
west again so wally west is very present
in Young Justice episodes even though
he's still bleep quote/unquote believed
to be dead which I've already done a
video about so if you haven't seen that
click here for my wally west video and
why he's probably coming back and click
here to rewatch that opening scene from
Young Justice season 3 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]